comment en sommes-nous arrivés ici cet endroit est
horrible
sent comme des balles nous avions tout tu étais
une star de cinéma souviens-toi que ce gars
était un homme sale j'aime cette affiche tu as écrit
cette adaptation que j'ai encore faite et tu
diriges et joues dans ton
adaptation ambitieuse avez-vous peur que les
gens disent que vous faites cette pièce
pour lutter contre l'impression que vous êtes un
personnage de bande dessinée échoué
absolument non c'est pourquoi il
y a vingt ans j'ai dit non à Birdman pour l'instant vous êtes
sur le point de détruire ce qui est  à gauche de ta
carrière on aurait dû faire cette
émission de téléréalité qu'ils nous proposent tu sais j'ai raison
ton sonar Hey alors qu'est-ce que tu essaies de te reposer un
peu avouons-
le papa tu fais ça parce que
tu es mort de peur comme les autres  d'entre
nous que tu n'as pas d'importance et tu sais
ce que tu as raison tu ne sais pas bébé peux-tu
me comprendre maintenant
parfois je deviens un peu en colère
ne sais-tu pas quand les choses vont
écouter tu es l'homme riche ne
Je ne fais pas de retour, c'est de ça que je parle
[Musique]
Oui, il va  sortir sur scène et
tout risquer pour faire quelque chose de bien, il
faut le prendre,
revenons en arrière une fois de plus et montrons-
leur de quoi nous sommes capables
là, vas-y, [ __ ]